All right, welcome everybody.
Appreciate everybody taking the time to be, uh,
with us for this session.
We're gonna, uh, go into some detail
as it relates to EverCommerce's,
uh, journey from a data
modernization effort.
Um,
let me start by introducing myself. I'm John
Sedlak with 5TR. I'm the vice president
of enterprise sales.
Um, and with me is Kalpit Patel,
uh, vice president of data and analytics
with, with EverCommerce. So we're
excited to be here. We've got a, a, a really
great, uh, lineup of questions. We're gonna go into
some detail.
Um, but let me start,
uh, for some of you that aren't familiar
with 5TR as a company,
um, we are a data
ingestion, data movement company focused
on automated,
secure, and scalable
data movement.
Um,
you'll see here we're about 1500
employees around the world.
Um,
and we focus on, um, specifically.
Operational data stores,
SAS applications.
We also work around, um,
uh, data tooling.
So the portfolio that we use
is, is broad as you can see. Oh, sorry,
I'm leaving you guys hanging with that. There you go.
Um,
it's very broad as far as the portfolio.
We have about 700 pre-built connectors
that our customers leverage.
Uh, think about things like, uh,
Salesforce and Zendesk,
Workday,
Google Ads from SAS key SAS
applications all the way through to
large operational data stores like
Oracle, SQL,
Sybase,
uh, DB2, and the list goes on.
Um,
we have about 7000 customers that
trust 5 Trans technology and 5
Trans teams
throughout the world, and we have a
global footprint both in North America,
Europe, and, uh, and Asia
Pacific, so you can see just a listing
of some of the, uh, the customers in
addition to EverCommerce
that, uh, have put, uh,
their business and their data movement,
um, business in the hands of,
of FiveTran.
So I'm gonna real quick talk about how
do we do this?
And then we'll jump into the
conversation with uh Kyle Pitt. So, as you
see here,
As it relates to AWS I'm gonna try to get
as specific as I can.
When you look on the left-hand side of the slide,
you'll see
that begins to indicate the portfolio
of source systems
that we move, right? You can see
everything from again,
operational data stores, SAS applications,
even digital tooling like GitHubs
and so forth.
The magic happens on the inside, right? Again,
as I mentioned earlier, 5TR has
automated, scalable,
and secure data pipelines. These are what we
deploy for our customers
to accelerate time to value,
speed to value, reducing overhead,
reducing cost.
These. Are maintained
by 5TR,
right? So these are automated pipelines. There's
no more management.
There's no more costs related to that. There's
no more schema drifts. All of these
things are automatically,
uh, accommodated and engineered
for as part of our platform.
We will ingest and move that data into.
Storage systems like S3 and we'll talk
a little bit more about that and the outputs as
you see on the far right hand side to speed
through this is
supporting everything from real-time analytics,
business operations, cloud migrations,
and what everybody is excited
about around AI and ML,
um, as well.
So with that,
I think what we'll do is we'll sit down, we'll
have a chit chat. Is that good for you?
Um,
and we'll talk a little bit with, with Capil
about why don't we start with you just introducing
yourself, uh, and your role at EverCommerce.
Perfect. Thank you so much, John. Uh, good
morning. Good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Kalpit Patel. I'm the VP
of enterprise data
at a company called EverCommerce.
Not sure if you guys know about EverCommerce,
uh, but, uh, we are an interesting
company. We are a
leading, uh.
Service commerce platform that
are digital native.
We provide solutions to
small business owners.
We are in about 40+ countries,
about 700,000 customers.
We really are very unique
in providing services to our customers
and our Purpose is very simple
to empower and digitally
make the service owners of this
small company very savvy. They
should not be worried about
what they
have to deal with from a technology landscape.
They just have to worry about running their businesses,
and that's what we really strive on.
So Capil, maybe
we could start
with, uh, sharing with
everybody here about, you know, with
the uniqueness of 50+
organizations,
um, and, and, you know, all
of them being kind of independently operated,
um,
what was the data infrastructure like as
you approach this modernization effort?
What was the original
state? So I was like every
other companies, right, uh,
when you go through buying portfolio of companies,
you really have to deal with, uh,
three different nuances, right?
People process,
technology, everybody knows it,
right? But when you look at the data infrastructure
at scale,
you. Think about silos of data,
duplications of data, right?
Really making sure the harmonization
is done properly.
But when I joined the organization about 18
months back,
it really struck me when I did about 60
interviews in my 1st 3 months, I went on a listening
tour. That we are a very data
hungry company.
And in order to turn that vision
from a data hungry
to a data enterprise and a data-led
company, you really need to provide
accessibility to
to data with the speed of light. And that's
how we really started our journey on
what I call is
AKA data factory. We will talk
more about what a data factories.
So you had these, you had these many,
many organizations, data hungry,
but there was really no organization
or plan, if you will, around
how to consolidate those from a
silo perspective into something more centralized.
Is that fair?
Yes, so again, like you know, for
within our commerce,
we don't say centralization. We
really say we are an
Enablement center because our goal is to really enable
the businesses and take them to
the next level whether it's in terms of
technology, but we are not building just a data
factory, we are enabling the future
of what our customers
want and need from us with the speed
of light.
Great, great segue. So as the business
scaled.
What were some of the,
the biggest challenges as you kind of
describe yourself getting
involved and doing a lot of interviews and understanding
the current state, but what were some of the biggest challenges
that you encountered with that decentralized
data? And then now here comes the plug for 5Tran.
Talk a little bit about how the managed data lake
service helped you accelerate that.
Perfect, right? So. Uh,
the three things that always comes
to data infrastructure and building
intelligence layer is, uh,
you first have to understand the business, right?
Everybody wants to do digital transformation,
right? But if you don't understand the
business landscape,
what the company is made up of, right,
it's going to be a very challenging task.
So for us, it's not about the issues on
hand, it's about the opportunities that brings
us and the. Opportunities are endless, right?
So having data in multiple
layouts, multiple formats,
because we, we bought a portfolio
of companies, it really is about
having them
all de-siloed. That's number one.
Second is, how do you provide
data accessibility as we talked about, right?
The third is, how do you really put
governance on top of all of this
in the world of AI,
right? Everybody. lacks two major
scenarios,
which is how do you bring data
together and how do you create a data
foundation
with a quality and a governed infrastructure.
Because once you have that, and that
we are calling it as a data factory. That's
our foundation. Our goal is to build a
factory. That's number 1 phase.
Second is lay the machinery in the factory.
And then the 3rd is build a factory and make
it ready. For rollout, right? So
those are the three phrases.
Uh, with FIRN,
we have been working with FITR for almost about
8, 10 years now.
Last year when I joined the organization, we
took a very strategic approach with FIRun.
Rather than using FIR in
individual companies,
we actually molded ourselves to
say, how can we use Fran
to build a data factory, empower
it. So we started. Using their
product called Managed Data Lake, right?
Our whole infrastructure and the platform
that we are building
is completely open data platform
on Apache iceberg, using,
uh, and leveraging the technologies of,
uh, PR, but we are building it on
the AWS S3 Foundation.
That's super rock solid, and foundational
in nature, and it provides the resiliency
and the infrastructure that we need.
Then with Fran,
right? It was always a question about should we
build it or should we buy it, as we have
been using F train,
we really decided to say, how
can we provide
acceleration,
speed, and the momentum
that the business has been hungry for
since so many years, right? So we decided to
use that approach, and then we started
really integrating all of these desperate sources,
leveraging fighter and managed data lake.
So we talked,
you talked
a bit about the technical implementations,
maybe talk a little bit about, you know, now with
the large portfolio of companies, how does that
affect cross-brand
visibility?
How does that
affect, you know, again, going back to the managed data lake
and the technology decisions, how does that
affect cross-selling, upselling
with utilizing that data? How has
that affected the business?
So again, like, you know, when you build a vision for
data factory,
right, uh, today, we are
able to run the mission
and the vision of our commerce. We are able to do
the reporting,
but it's not at the level that we
want, uh, in terms of empowerment
of our customers, right? So, when we enable
the data factory,
now we are able to
build once and consume many times.
So when Talk about data assets. You're
bringing in data assets. You are
governing those data assets. You are providing
quality on those data assets,
right, in one lens, rather
than having 1020, 30 different
systems that are disintegrated,
right? So for a perfect example is today
because of the data factory,
we will now have a
very
focused view on how is the. Targeting
working right? What is our
achievement scores, right? How is the funnel working?
What is the lead generation,
right? We can now start putting more
lens around enterprise reporting.
How can we have standardized data definitions?
Everybody just focuses on the
technology side of the house.
For us, it was more around the change management,
really making sure that the business has the
buy-in. It's not about. Rolling out data
factory. It's about solving the business
problems that we see currently,
but also build the data factory that is built
for the future, that is
AI enabled, but it also has an AI
migration lens coming from
legacy as well, right? So
more enterprise lands,
build once, consume many times, and
also provide self-service applicability
to our business users.
And then kind of
now pivoting over to the, to the
Amazon, the S3 side.
What was,
what was your decision process like to choose
S3 from a, a storage perspective?
So, uh.
In our current landscape, we
have AWS, we have Azure, we have a
lot of other cloud providers,
but, uh, because we
have been working with AWS for quite a while,
we wanted a rock solid foundation
layer, right? For us,
everything has to be fundamentally.
In a shape that you are not just
able to bring the data, but you are able to
transform, you are able to mold it, and
S3 provides us that when you,
when you have about 100 different connectors
that you are running
on a minute, on a 10 minutes, on an
hour scale, you really want that
integration to be flawless, and S3
is probably one of Best engines that are out
there. So if you couple that
with fight and managed data lake,
building medallion architectures on an
open architecture using Apache iceberg,
now you're not just building for the future,
but you are building for use cases that
might come when you're
looking at the infrastructure from a scale.
You, you, you answered the, the follow-on
question I was gonna ask you just around how 5-chan
helped accelerate that centralization
and, and, uh, you know, you talked about
the managed
data lake service. Are there any other
projects specific to, as we're talking
about managed data lake service, we're
talking about S3, any future
projects that you can kind of describe to
the audience, uh, you know, that you
have uh in the roadmap as it relates
to that? So I think from a future. Project
perspective, as I said, our, uh, goal
first was to lay out the factory.
Now that we are done with that goal,
we are really empowering and enabling
our infrastructure to be AI and ML
ready. All right? Uh, what does that
mean is
today, if we have to look at customer churn
or customer retention because the data was
in so many different landscape, it was
very hard to do that.
Now that we are bringing the data in one
place, we can really run
sophisticated.
algorithms
across the portfolio of companies to see, for
example, if a culprit was buying
product 17, and 10,
now we have full visibility into how
can you do upsell, cross sell,
propensity,
customer churn, retention
in terms of Pre helping us,
we also are planning to leverage Fran ecosystems
holistically. We are a big DBT
shop right now with the integration of Fran
and DBT
that is going. To accelerate us in our journey
in automating a lot of what I call a shift
lap technology, right? Shift lap means you really
want to govern the data, qualify
the data as soon as you load them
and not bring them into your ecosystems
all the way on the tail end. So we are a
big fan of really doing
quality in shift lab when you
bring it from the source systems
because bad data is depth data, right? If
you bring in bad data, you'll have to really
pay a lot of debt.
So you began to, to touch on
a topic
that I wanted to bring us back to, uh, which
is that 360 degree journey.
So as some may know, the, uh,
you know, 5TR and DBT are in the
process
of, uh, becoming one company. So super
exciting and more, more of that is,
is unfolding here as the weeks go on.
But, uh, we've also gone through a
process of acquiring, uh, a company called Census
around. Uh, reverse ETL.
So when you think about that 360-degree
journey,
incorporating
the 5 trans,
the DBTs,
the census, how does that play into
the architecture that, that you've
already developed up to this point?
So I think with our commerce, as I said, we are
very unique.
We are a very digitally savvy company,
right? So we don't think technology first. We
think about what is the business transformation
that we want to lay out.
So from a future perspective,
we created something called DNA flywheel,
and the DNA flywheel really
understands who is the producer of the data,
who is going to consume that data, what.
And fight trains, sensors, DBT,
a lot of other technologies.
But for us,
we don't go to the business and say, here
are the technologies. We say we are building a
factory right for the future
that is the data factory, and the data
factory is powered by an engine
like Fran, like DVTs of the
world. That is to really make the
Life is easy for our engineers, right?
And then we are putting an AIML
on top of it with API as a
service data monetization, which
is our nirvana state going forward
to really see how can you enable
the businesses at scale. So it's all about
digitally savvy business
units driving forward innovation.
Amazing.
Um,
there's a lot there. You guys have, have
deployed a lot. You've, you've been with the company
for, uh, uh, not a long time, and
what you've accomplished with your team in
that short period of time is amazing
with partnering with the AWS
team, with the Five Tra team.
I know you have a, a whole series of other vendors
that have been a part of that as well, um.
We are going to, you know, there's a lot
that we talked about here and we're gonna make
everybody available to stop by our booth,
and I'll put it up here, booth 1660.
Uh, Capil will be there as well,
uh, to answer any questions,
um, as it relates to
the, the, uh, information that we shared today as
it relates to 5TR and what we're doing with
EverCommerce and what we're doing with some
of the other companies out there. So, um,
I wanna thank everybody for, uh, for joining
us. Appreciate it.
Thank you everybody, uh, for letting us share
our stories, right? And then, uh, thank you, Fran,
right, for being a good success partners, right, along
with AWS. Appreciate it.